There are a variety of different approaches to implementing generalization in
object oriented languages.
One that we just alluded to, is inheritance that follows specific rules.
Second, you could just simply use a single class that has some kind of flag
that indicates whether a particular instance is of a certain type, and you might
have multiple types and the fly could have multiple different, different values.
If you did that you would then be hiding the child data that particular type
inside that that that class as indicated by the flag.
In Java you could use interfaces or enums which are two mechanisms that
allow you that enforce the rules that I've that I've laid out,
you can use the state pattern when we get to design patterns you'll see.
That there might be situations where you want
to have some flexibility that's not provided by using strict sub-classing.
For example imagine that you're implementing a, application having to
do with a library and the library might have different categories of books.
It might have one-week books, two-weeks books,
four-week books, and it would, might be natural to say well,
I'll have three subclasses of the, of the class book.
But what happens when a one-week book becomes a two-week book?
And auditory language is you can't change the class of something.
Once you've established as as being of a class, it's, it's there for ever.
So the state patterns allow, allows you to have a way to have
dynamically be able to adjust the class of an object.
And then for languages like C++ that have multiple inheritance, this gives you
the, the ability to specify the properties that you wish to inherit in more
than one class and be able to inherit from those classes just what you need.